so welcome to the studio thank you for
having me good to see you you're in Made
in Chelsea and I think it's safe to say
that you had a very explosive beginning
to this show
absolutely let's take a look I knew you
had a girlfriend but last night I lost
you nude up but you were still fluttered
with it thirty first nineteen you just
[ __ ] we got booked often why are you
worried about what I do when your
boyfriend because I don't appreciating
on a rose okay
amazing great I'm a okay so you know
what was it like I guess stepping into
that world for you really interesting
actually I'd never done a show like made
Michelle see before I've never really
done TV before it was it was intense but
you know what it's I've learned a lot
from it and it's a lot easier after my
first series I just now have the
complete hang of things like epic ending
I was a bit nervous and I didn't know
exactly what I was doing I just kind of
was going with the flow but now I think
I have my ground I know exactly kind of
what to do has it also affected your
real life like when you're not filling
the show in your out how are you dealing
with that yeah you know like it it is
real life so it is my real life and I do
hang out with those people and it's
completely a representation that was my
life so when I'm not filming when the
cameras are in front of me you know I
still do the same things it's those
friends on the show we go for lunches
and dinners and stuff and but I had the
public react to you is what it was f
initely been recognized yeah and it's
weird because I never really had people
come to me ask for photos before but
even like the other day I was at a
coffee shop a night oh my Instagram did
I get into the story of the coffee shop
and you know people were outside like
lining up to take photos of me and I was
like what the hell this is so weird I've
never had something like that before
yeah um so you know it's a big it's a
big shock of the system but I love it
and I love meeting people and it's
really fun yeah so we ran into Jeannie
Bouchard your cousin several weeks ago
and she had a question for you you
should ask her what really goes on on
those reality shows because she's on
Made in Chelsea yeah though I want to
know you know the backstage kind of
secrets videos any at least one
backstage secret that you can share with
her and share with us you guys I'm
telling you right now like it's little
peaceful we've real like there's no
backstage secrets like it's completely
not scripted and but does it give you
scenarios and to like set you up for a
situation yeah well you know if I'm
going for lunch with let's Sato Fenella
they'll film it so you know if I didn't
want to do something I didn't have to do
at the end of the day so it is - from
the hills yeah completely at Frank yeah
because the hills they would set up
scenarios and say we need you to sort of
have this happen somehow in that but
there's none of that alike so it's very
organic yeah Wow fantastic well
congratulations thank you so much and
thanks for having me